our next guest is primarily known for
his disappointing baseball career an
incredible luck at marrying the talented
and beautiful Ciara he also happens to
play football and if this interview is
anything like the games he played in
2019 it'll start off slow and then it'll
come on strong at the end he's a dear
friend of the show and will definitely
say go Hawks at some point very soon
please welcome the lovely and talented
Russell Wilson run it on here well go
Hawks
I gotta start with the jacket here yep
you can I guess orange corduroy well you
know I feel like I'm in Miami and
obviously you know I had to bring some
color to the to the to the area you know
so it'll be a little vibrant for you
Paulie is already shopping online for
that I would crush in Vermont with that
run he tried to take it off my backstage
that looks good though yeah how you
doing great man how you been I'm good
Congrats on baby number three yes it's
exciting baby it on three it's going on
the way okay I fired above that when is
the baby due
I can't tell you all that yeah I don't
want the whole world to know that what
you told the whole world you're having
another man but you know it's it's it's
it's due within the next nine months so
it's probably due in the next
usually you like to wait a certain
amount of time so I'm gonna guess seven
months from now who knows okay baby okay
we want to come up do you know what it
is not yet we're gonna find out soon
though what do you think it is a pity
pity chance I think it's a girl I think
it's a girl yeah you know the funny
thing is my brother's had all girls you
know and you know so he's had three
girls so far I had Sienna so you know
I'm not sure I'm not sure about my odds
right now I got three girls - really
yeah boy all the girls are awesome every
day I get to see Sienna it's like well
they're with you the rest of your life
like my son might come back into my life
at some point you know he's off
travel in the world like my girls are
always gonna be there they'll take care
of me when I'm old
well the funny thing about it's like
Siena and I it's like you know as soon
as as soon as your baby's born
it's like you're automatically
protective you are no boy is nothing so
I'm already playing then my head no all
right we were gonna come up with names
here do you up for your baby how about
the gloving who make the Aven Wilson
McLovin do you have a name for us this
baby yeah it was it was pretty what do
you have I'm Rudy for a daughter so they
can call the baby three are I'm writing
these down you we're number three I do
so three are three our third kid number
three boy you could call it Trey Russell
care pretending like no no no that
Russell's like my own camera yes you are
I got react an appropriate way Seaton
I'm going with a nod to your alma mater
there I'm going Madison Madison
Wisconsin track my former teammates in
the crowd right now from Madison's all
right okay my god all right this is too
easy Ross if it's a boy Hawk Wilson
he said Hawk Hawk Wilson that's good I
like it seems seems tenacious every
morning he goes to school again i'ma go
Hawk what if it's a girl
Hawk Wilson whatever no middle name not
to waste of time she still even
dominating middle names are useless huh
well no sometimes did you bring him in
there
I killed ooh what is your middle name my
middle name is Carrington Russel
Carrington Wilson
it should be Russell Wilson Carrie Clark
that laugh was going too hard
sorry the quarterback run you'll be fine
for that would be oh yeah for sure
I'm not allowed to laughing you're
allowed to laugh for sure but that
that's excessive laughs okay this was
too much I tried again what's your
middle name
also Carrington Wilson who is the the
kangaroo court there and with the
Seahawks well technically it's it's kind
of everybody's a partially a judge but
I'm the real Supreme Court judge you are
yeah so give me an example of a
violation well first of all throwing
some light on the bus that's one another
thing would be you know bad hygiene
that's another you know yeah you have
some guys that come in and those we call
shower pill but would literally come in
and just you know not really take a
shower
hey that's that's a fine for [ __ ]
you would drive by yeah just kind of a
quick rinse a bad fart that's one I get
fine for that sometimes I don't
[Music]
so how much how much is a bad fart cost
it's about it's about $35 $35 okay
that's how bad it is though right so you
know sometimes he may be sick so we'll
give you a little grace but if it's
really bad you don't give any warning
that's that's not good are you letting
the hair grow long I'm going to go along
right now why do you think it looks it
looks full I don't know are you looking
for the European rust this is like Oh
your arrest
oh really yeah this is like long hair
motor Payton had that in the 70s yeah I
had that that law that's a good one now
do you use an activator on that no it's
just water shampoo conditioner and
that's pretty much it I know I put a
little lotion it's a little trick with
actually learning the long game the
grandmother taught me there's your wife
pick out your clothes she pick out my
clothes yeah no but she definitely does
give me the look like uh don't wear that
does she have veto power if she goes
like this okay
I and she closes one is a no now if she
asks you how she's looking oh you look
great there no matter what
no matter I figure you're rooting for
the Chiefs because you can't root for
the Niners right I'm not rooting for
anybody I'm learning for Hawk you know
but I think to watch this game Jimmy
great game because obviously the
defensive line
you know the 49ers spectacular and then
you know that caused a lot of habit we
got to play them twice and they were
epic games I mean it felt like it was
the NFC Championship game and both of
those games you know how that game went
down and then and then obviously
patching the homes either store he's got
so many weapons I mean these guys that
he has you know run around the field
that the track stars they can catch they
can all do a lot of great things and
Kelsey is a big factor too so I think
that I think his ability to scramble
will probably be the separator in this
game
I love Legion of zoom the same for the
Chiefs with the name of the wide
receivers uh-huh nice how good who's
that that's a good one not as good as
Legion of boom but yeah Legion Legion of
bovis this story doesn't the Chiefs it
feels like they could field a four by
100 relay to know for sure they and they
would have backups yes mike is Tyreke
the fastest guy in the league I would
think so for sure but he just that one
game I don't know what game it was but
he caught up to the guy and that was
incredible I've never seen anything like
that okay what is that if Patrick
mahomes called you up and said hey Russ
got anything for me with the Niners I
mean I think I think takeaway they give
you because they're gonna apply playoffs
um and you know try to you know emit
make them throw completions all the way
down the field because they're gonna bet
that hey our defense line will get to
him at some point and then when he has a
chance to scramble you got to make those
plays you know because a scrambling part
of its gonna be key you know can it can
the defensive line get to him can both
so get to them can arm stick and those
guys get to them so I think that's gonna
be key in the separator in this game is
the up tempo and the scrambling part of
what mahomes can do or what he may not
be able to do the Niners say anything to
you when you did they say anything yeah
I mean they they talked a little bit
like what what is said well I mean I I
think that uh throughout the game I
don't say anything because the times
that I have said something like three
times
happen to me in college once I talked a
little trash said too much and
play was not good and it happened to me
my rookie year and my second year so
ever since I've never said really
anything outside of you know you know
talking to my guys well what do they say
to you they try to get in my head they
tell you I guess you're short you know
don't you quit slide and you know oh all
that kind of stuff you know
DuBose to say anything to you not really
you know he's a he's a playmaker though
he you know you to me I'm one of those
guys I respect guys who can really play
so you know I'll give him a shout-out
manly house a nice play bro you know
that kind of thing and well back and
forth he'll say the same thing kind of
thing but do you think that you could be
nice to them and then that they'll be
nicer to you yeah maybe that works I
don't know I don't think they really
care but the one guy don't talk much to
is sure because I know he'll win you
know cuz he just he's such a good trash
talker so I don't even bother with it's
like it's like dealing with Gary Payton
you know just sometimes Oh Joe that's a
good call Gary Payton was pretty good
yeah yeah but Sherm is waiting for
somebody to engage with it yeah it kind
of like gets you motivated we're talking
to Russell Wilson you know I started to
think about this too when you know you
have that chip on your shoulder yeah you
know Brady had it it feels like these
guys and you carry it forever uh-huh
you're going to the Hall of Fame but at
what point do you take that chip off
your shoulder and maybe create some I
mean it's hard for something you to say
hey nobody you know respects me or I
don't get any publicity I mean you're
one of the great you're the guy I would
have if the game is on the line in a
two-minute drill like you've proven
yourself well I don't think the chip
ever leaves I think the the the mindset
of a champion it wakes up a thirsty it
wakes up hungry you know and if you want
to be great it's got to be something
that you stayed you read that in a book
or something dude you know I just
thought of it but you know it kind of
just came together as one
but it's it's true it's it really it
really does happen that way you know I
think about you know trying to be great
every single day and one of the things
that I got to think about it's not just
trying to be great on the field because
if you just try to be great in the field
and you know you're gonna be let down at
some point you know but if you can try
to be great in all you know all your
categories you know I was at the Pro
Bowl and you know bill green actually
was I got to talk to him he played 20
years in FL he talked about being great
in all five categories of your life you
know and the first thing he said is your
faith the second thing was your
relationship with your wife
the third thing he said with your family
the fourth thing is said with your
profession whatever your profession is
and then he said the fifth thing was
with your community community be a
hundred percent in all five categories
and I love that I love that breakdown in
that analogy because you can't be great
a hundred percent for all twenty things
but the five you can manage and the
energy and the focus and the detail and
the love and the passion that you put in
all five of those things those are
things that you can control that's how
you become great and so you know for me
I that that edge that that thirst that
hunger every is is every morning I saw
you tweeted out a picture celebrity
softball game with Kobe yeah yeah when
was that
intercepted that was Super Bowl we won
and we had firm actually had an awesome
softball you know game it was currently
safe it was Safeco Field back then now
t-mobile Park and in Seattle and we had
a bunch of people there and they had a
bunch of celebrities and everything else
and my favorite celebrity I got to meet
was Kobe you know and be around him a
little bit cuz one he was so gracious he
was so amazing with people you know and
you know there's there's really two
people that I've always noticed that
with Kobe Bryant
Magic Johnson I remember I met Magic
Johnson my rookie year and he was
amazing with these with these young kids
that all came up to me he just was so
patient and then Kobe was the same way
he was a teacher he taught things
obviously the game of basketball but he
taught told how to love he taught how
you know with his kids and stuff he
always brought them around he
he taught other he would teach other
kids you know and other players you know
as you know you know a young young buck
in the NFL you know how to do things and
so it was always cool to be around him
in that sense and so anyways that
picture though it was two moments I had
the picture of my arms out he has turned
up and that was after he had an awesome
I think he hit a home run and that play
it was a cool play and then there was
another picture I'm kind of sneaking up
behind him and I actually did a trick
play on him he was on third base and he
he would kind of sneak off the bag you
know and I had the hidden ball trick
yeah you know hey Kobe you know it's
it's sad you know obviously to think
about you know what he's what do you
know him going and GG and all the
families because he's meant so much to
so many people and the sport of
basketball and you know I used to fly
helicopters you know I stopped that the
moment that I heard that you know it was
you know it's so you would use
helicopters to get yeah go from you know
a Seattle all that stuff and no more
that no more for me you're working for
NFL flag yeah exciting huge partnership
businesses are you in Rus well I got a
few you know
Mark Wahlberg that's you're like getting
a lot of things well you know for me
whenever I was in high school in college
I was always busy I took 18 credits play
two sports me being busy it keeps me
focused
but yes West East is my biggest company
it's kind of my holding company it's my
incubator for everything all my thoughts
all my ideas all the things we do my
production company my management company
so we do everything out of there so it's
it's pretty exciting what we've been on
to do with west to east and but the cool
part with NFL flag is really exciting
because we're going global I get to be
you know co-owner and chairman of NFL
flag and partnership with the NFL and
reigning champs that's a really exciting
thing there's over 500,000 kids
currently they're playing flag football
and in America and three NFL flag and
it's really exciting what they're doing
and you know we mean cierra we've been
going on this kind of global trip you
know for the past couple years we've
gone to China have gone to Brazil we've
gone to UK and and
being very intentional about where we're
going how we're doing and gone to Canada
and and football is really growing there
and the cool part is is that boys and
girls were playing we went to Brazil
I'll give you the example I went to
Brazil last last spring last summer and
we were there first of all you know
Carnaval was amazing but also we I got
to meet and spend a lot of time with
about 120 kids that were that were that
were playing flag football and boys and
girls all different ages and everything
else and one of the cool things that I
that I figured out and talked to them
about us
they saw the game and said you know when
we see the game an American football
they said it seems like we can't do it
like you know it seems very expensive
first of all it seems like it's doesn't
make sense for us to do because they're
so used to playing soccer and basketball
there's a ball and a goal you know and
there's a soccer ball and two goals and
the reality about flag football is it
gives it gets kids of potential to learn
the game experience the game and play it
anywhere and everywhere and you know
it's affordable and it's safe and it's
exciting to be partnered up with a you
know obviously NFL flag and to be able
to be coke you know
co-owner and chairman of that with with
the team it's great to see you and
congrats on the baby news there thank
you yeah you know what I think how about
for a girl Carol Carol you know my
grandmother's name is Carolyn so keep
Carol beastmode for maybe beastmode it's
great to see you always great thank you
you guys four more Dan Patrick show tune
in to audience channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]